i
[Music]
bubble 23 of the person you
charge frictions tacos of the Russian
we had the sighs
[Music]
and those
[Laughter]
[Music]
of not having money on facebook
ok
dining room and this
questioned by  500 hours this
Sunday and not the debate store
ii
[Laughter]
[Music]
el baradei ok mind flex road alive
my name is walter soto and we are from tacos or
the Russian I and julia silva work
at my mom friend yes she  she takes care of
the meats and I take care of the afternoons she
arrives she takes care of the
tortillas I just
started at 17 I started they were more or
less in the state of sinaloa in a
lychee cart it is still there it is the
best I wanted and in  Sinaloa and the Lord, well,
as he says, he adopted me
after that I came here and there was a lot of sun
now when I met Julia no one
fell in love with Julia and well until now
you know we fought but it
's normal between all of us that she
concludes that Julián has a good hand
for the tortillas
my name is j  Ulia Silva and I'm from Mexico
from Sonora, true, the
company's tortilla will be the age they taught me to
make when I was four years old, my
mother was eight years old at the time, and today it
was two days to sell them, a
sobaquera is a large tortilla,
they call it a tortilla  water because it hardly
has any butter and it is a large tortilla
to make the burritos because they are
large and there are people who make them
that come up here to the
arm
if it is the tortilla and we put the cheese on
the grill and then we put the tortilla
above, since we only turn it a little bit,
we smear it with 300 beans
and put the meat that people
ask us for, it is made of flour, make a lot of
red chili, the mole
of roasted birria and chorizo because it was a pure rival
in pure quality and pure calyx  I
am left with pure quality and I was looking
for the equation but I remembered not posture
quality pure quality
are like details but I think that if
you have to have a little discipline to
be able to do  doing things as they
should be
the most the most
regarding food you play with tacos
the russian useful to choose from in boyle
heights immersion great amazing south
of that alone that was useful to conclude
today 16 tortilla it is expected that in the
camp  it only remains that the bottom
world only with a duration of more than
colonet is location of imei lay condemns
tortillas juan inside the armpit good
rule the law says of april and to have my
family
recent efe this new version
[Music]
for jiménez
tacos
in the  act
in the field his website
the pastor tuesday by drive my
self pastor frank to taquería
el tapatío to leave the tortas to
resort to a victory of tortas
preserve the pastor of the stanton sector
in particular let's give them the inflate bike
live the water staves  from red
love the one from green the goal from green radio
unam like I showed up at media banda
night the big taco can become
the soccer saga
[Music]
at half past los angeles time on the
boat
e  this usually drags me by grace of
authority before ghana for high damages
of the attractiveness of this river cooking
for steaks
in its profile
eating and drinking
in the abdomen two meters stronger
none of that
[Laughter] it
costs five comedians from two factories
george karl  an
hélimer end of records
steve martin
at racing grasso who wanted more
highlights with everyone and sat down on his tennis as it
is to project my role as president
thanks for everything in other teams well they
seem to warm up a euphoria is with
the student trace in person in
progress march 6 in  their countries
[Music]
different from the same long time friends
and home and satin and thicknesses facebook
el pastor tacos which sleeps
the veins in the debut after having the
russian in boyle heights alcoholics weiss
a swing or in a version in halves of the
russian although  you hit me at 12
rib breaker ones
a few days ago in cannes hugs
jesús trejo
[Music]